[Musique]
chantal lavigne avec 35 ans elle avait
rencontré patrick nous il y a dix ans on
s'entendait très bien de rased qu'en
pensera portrait puis pendant de longues
années la mèche pas les choses fait la
manne sont fait que quand j'ai proposé
le médiéval tout embarqué patrick naud
est un amateur de médiéval c'est même
son métier
chantal suit nos sa passion jusque dans
leur mariage dans la famille c'est elle
la terre à terre celle qui tient les
cordons de la bourse
ben a toujours fait de travail de bureau
dans le fond grave à cause de ses études
qui est toutefois bien placé la panouse
à retrouver un emploi
juste après un problème pour elle après
leur mariage chantal lavigne et patrick
nous ont deux enfants une fille et un
garçon qui ont maintenant sept et trois
ans
chantal lavigne est une mère dévouée
pour la bst a été l'hôte où l'on parle
on est deux ans et plus l'eau à s'en
occuper tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps
mais après la naissance du deuxième
enfant les choses changent
chantal est de moins en moins présente
elle a commencé quelques mois plus tôt à
fréquenter un groupe de croissance
personnelle dont des millions patrie
vous l'apprendre je pense est du reiki
ou différentes choses comme ça puis elle
a entendu parler de ce thème adam loi
qui faisait différentes trans des choses
comme ça cette dame c'est gabriel
fréchette 53 ans qui se fait aussi
appeler serena depuis plus de 20 ans
cette femme prétend qu'un esprit prend
possession de son corps et qu'il parle à
travers l on appelle cela la
canalisation l'esprit qu'elle canalise
s'appelle melchisédech personnages cités
dans la bible son nom veut dire en
hébreu roi de la justice et de la paix
melchisédech est aussi le nom de la
fiducie de gabriel fréchette qui offre
des centaines de cours liés au
développement personnel
elle fait aussi des rencontres privées
une première rencontre a eu lieu entre
gabriel fréchette et chantal lavigne en
2007 enquête a obtenu l'enregistrement
sonore de cette rencontre comme ce
village crête avons veillé à ce qu'il
ait naître chez gabriel ferez chef dit à
chantal lavigne que dans ses vies
antérieures
elle s'est éloignée de sa mission sur
terre pour réparer les erreurs de ses
vies antérieures
il faudrait qu'elle fasse des oeufs de
sudation et de respiration intensive
il en fallait dès cette première
rencontre
elle recommande plusieurs cours à
chantal lavigne
nous sommes à vous révéler tous les plus
grands secrets de wagram
c'est le commencement d'une existence
une nouvelle nous après cette séance
chantal lavigne commence un programme
intensif de formation en vue de changer
de carrière et d'offrir des traitements
énergétique
patrick nous accepte tant bien que mal
la situation
mais cette eau des choses que moi je
crois pas facture est au départ j avais
dit tu m'as parle le moins possible
accepter ce vraiment important at en
quarts puis vie d'un patient je vis la
mienne quand un autre jour faire profond
chantal lavigne signe un contrat de
trois ans avec melchisédech les
formations se succèdent les unes aux
autres
la saq a man semble déranger un petit
peu parce que j'ai vu la liste de 300
pompiers
c'était une semaine par mois deux
semaines pendant trois semaines pas
moins sa chablis toute façon vive au
complet chantal est de moins en moins à
la maison en juillet dernier le couple
planifie de partir en vacances mais à la
dernière minute
chantal annonce à patrick qu'elle doit
suivre un autre chemin
il est furieux c'était hors de question
c'est notre temps ensemble avec les
enfants pourront s'amuser puis on
prenait nos vacances mais d'abord nous
puis fall absolue m'accueille alpha
cayeux été
c'est dans une maison de durham sud où
chantal lavigne et alliés une maison où
depuis au moins un an
les voisins s'inquiètent de ce qui se
passe là bas roxane labonté habite juste
en face puis à raison de deux à trois
fois par semaine le temps mort
ressortait les gens se rassemblaient
l'obs à crier puis des trous de cris
intense
elle file le moment donné ça nous sommes
alarmés j'entendais les femmes criaient
laissez moi sortir j'ai mal aux gens
j'ai mal au ventre puis ça criait
détruites détresse que je veux des
frissons partout
roxane labonté et si inquiète qu'elle
appelle le 9e à l'arrivée des policiers
le groupe est calme et les policiers
repartent sans rien faire quelques jours
plus tard celle qui habite cette maison
vient voir roxane labonté et son mec là
pour les rassurer on veut je suis dit
que mon épouse monde mes chances boucle
et j'entendais ce qui se passait puis le
dorénavant on va faire sans dans les
portes fermées les fenêtres fermées puis
nous ce qu'on fait c'est un peu une
forme de chaînes de chamanisme du 17 au
31 juillet dernier c'est à cet endroit
qui avec huit autres personnes chanteuse
va suivre ce qui sera son dernier
séminaire
le titre de ce séminaire mourir en
conscience
si j'ai bien compris s'ils prennent un
poster cours là et surtout celui de le
dernier dans le fonds même même toutes
les eaux il y avait quelque chose de
très très graves qui allait arriver en
avi
il y a une semaine que le séminaire et
comment ces différentes activités autour
maintenant gabriel fréchette alias
serena alias melchisédech décide que les
participantes doivent regarder la mort
en pleine face ils seront tous à tour de
rôle
enfermé nu dans un cercueil nous avons
obtenu les enregistrements sonores de
cette séance
ce que vous allez entendre c'est la voix
de gabriel fléché nous avons reconstitué
le lieu de la mise en cercueil que vous
allez voir c'est ce qu'a vécu
chantal lavigne serena donne ses
directives à ses deux assistants ou
avez-vous situé derrière parce que c'est
mieux de cercles du pouvoir le planifier
est il possible de venir barret moi je
pense qu'apple ne pas exercer lettre
earl là pour que vous décidiez sortez
vous ne bougez droit de grâce et dont
les décès lettre ne peut voir venir des
centaines une borne est l'antre à
l'intérieur vous référer au clos de
chantal lavigne a passé 3 ar enfermé
dans ce cercueil
c'était la veille de sa mort
[Musique]
tous les participants du séminaire à
mourir en conscience était très impliqué
dans le groupe big c dès qu ils étaient
neuf ans tous deux 27 à 69 ans cinq
québécois et quatre français gabriel
fréchette donne des formations depuis 20
ans et affirme que plus de 2000
personnes ont suivi ces enseignements
nous avons voulu savoir si le groupe
était toujours actif depuis la mort de
chantal lavigne un des assistants de
gabriel fréchette gerald de fontaine 39
ans est ma sara adan ville
l'autre assistante de gabriel fréchette
ginette duclos 60 ans travaille à saint
germain de grantham
c'est sur un site internet conscience
famille qu'on la retrouve cet ancien
cadre de chez bell offre maintenant ses
services comme éveilleur de conscience
nous sommes allé la rencontrer
avec une caméra cachée
[Musique]
oui c'est un homme à tout bien guidé
c'est ça ne tourne ahmed a appuyé ces
noms la semaine suivante il a tout de
suite un autre rendez vous
gillett duclos parle pour la première
fois de melchisédech mellick sidère
c'est un match intéressant c'est
quelqu'un qui canalise la mixité c'est à
dire c'est une entité c'est une énergie
qui viendra vers un corps humain pour
parler vous où les eaux puisque on va me
dire moi je suis médium conscient médium
conscient ça veut dire que je canalise
une énergie mais je vais pas où j'ai
quitté mon corps beau que l'énergie rend
un médium d'un concert mais l'excès d'un
crime la personne qui canalise mais que
c'était
c'était le gabriel serré nomme et
l faut qu'un kit son camp c'est comme
une mort consciente a fait jouer non non
parce que c'est ça s'apprend pour cette
journée mais des apprentissages chantal
lavigne en avait fait plusieurs plus de
85 cours qui durait d'une journée à deux
semaines des diplômes de reiki mâitre
initiateurs qu'en conscience mettra la
clef d'argent rituel initiatique pour
former les gens les chevaliers de
l'ordre de merlin à lui des boxes
certificat pour chaque co mais chantal
n'obtiendra jamais de diplômes pour ce
qui sera son dernier séminaire
cette fois ci la séance est une
situation dans laquelle elle va trouver
la mort encore une fois tout le son a
été enregistré et nous avons obtenu ces
enregistrements et encore une fois on
entend la voix de gabriel fréchette qui
s'exprime comme s'il était possédée par
l'esprit de melchisédech donc nous
prévoyons approximativement 12 à 14
heures
gabriel ferez chef demande à ses
assistantes que chacune des personnes
soient nus couverte de boue et enveloppé
dans une bâche de plastique
par la suite elles seront recouvertes de
plusieurs couvertures et elles auront la
tête dans une boîte de carton pour
magnifier l'être dans sa tête on le
modifier par la couverture et vous
revendiquiez et des plastiques en règle
[Rires]
tous les participants sont maintenant
regroupés et enveloppé gabriel fréchette
leur parle en mille qui cdec dimension
matière de mourir perception de la vie
sur terre
les revenus de mourir que vous croyez la
sudation est en cours depuis plusieurs
heures
l'enregistrement a été arrêté il reprend
ainsi ses deux cas la mort est la
liberté
la mort c'est la vérité la mort est leur
retour à dieu dû rapidement
[Musique]
c'est maintenant les assistants ginette
duclos et gerald de fontaine qui
prennent la relève pour inciter le
groupe a continué à hyperventiler
pendant la sudation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce sont les derniers mots enregistrés
mais la séance a duré neuf heures
[Musique]
nous avons obtenu les déclarations
faites aux policiers par les personnes
présentes on y apprend que plusieurs
participants ont été malades
moi j'ai vomi une fois rendu à ma
chambre je suis allé prendre une douche
je ne me sentais pas très bien j'ai vomi
en y allant d'ailleurs je n'ai aucune
idée de combien de temps j'ai respiré
rapidement de cette façon avant de
m'évanouir
chantal avait de la difficulté à
respirer qu'elle n'a jamais ouvert les
yeux
serena a appelé à info santé qui lui ont
dit de faire immédiatement le 9 heures
[Musique]
les ambulances a même julie et chantal à
l'hôpital de drummondville
quelques heures plus tard dans un
dernier espoir de la souris chantal
laver ou sera transférée à l'hôpital de
sherbooke el himma
[Musique]
comment une marque chantal l'année elle
est morte d'une hyperthermie à partir
d'une certaine température quand le
corps devient trop chaud il ya tout un
tas de systèmes qui fonctionnent plus
correctement alors c'est le cerveau
c'est une fois c'est l'iran par des
idées notation c'est une insuffisance
multi organes finalement le docteur
gilles sainton est urgentologue au
centre hospitalier de sherbrooke
il est coronaire dans le dossier de
chantal lavigne sa température à
l'arrivée à drummondville donc
finalement au moins à peu près 1000
heures après qu'elle soit sortie de ses
couvertures étaient encore à 40.5 degrés
celsius ce qui est énorme
dans sa déclaration aux policiers
gabriel fréchette a déclaré
selon moi il devait déjà y avoir quelque
chose qui clochait
au niveau de sa santé chatel et ligne
avait pas de problème de saint clément
cédant aucun problème au sein de
l'article met définitivement le coup de
chaleur
la mise en condition en cui semble qu'il
a fait des choses on va retrouver très
très très souvent une sorte d' escalade
dans les pratiques diam casoni et
criminologue
elle étudie les groupes de croissance
personnelle malgré une importante la
régie elle nous a accordé une entrevue
aussi dans l'année au il est suffisant
de méditer sans boire ni manger pendant
huit heures maintenant l'année deux dans
l'année 3 dans l'année car il va falloir
faire quelque chose de plus on pourra
pas se contenter de la même expérience
et c'est là que ça devient dangereux
qui sait serena qui canalise et gabriel
qui canalise dans city mexique
ça
oui c'est stationnaire c'est un nouveau
monde qui s'ouvrira demain qui arrive
est dans une situation où on
l'encouragent de smith toute une série
de concours titres choisis l'initiation
re à qui je dédie 650 $ pour les deux
jours la pression moi je te suggère
d'aller chercher l'outil d'unification
avec saucisson lalart après sauvé si tu
veux inspirer ses semblables
d'après ce que dit quoi toujours la
question à quel moment vous êtes rendu
compte de à quel point savait déjà mais
après le dos au mur a lui aussi ses
cartes de crédit pour voitures et des
montants cash cadeaux naseaux pour payer
les coûts chantal lavigne avait signé un
contrat de trois ans pour ces formations
avec milk cdec pour 18900 dollars et
elle avait ajouté continuellement des
cours sur ce parcours 10 de l'homme mais
j'aurais peut-être obligé de vendre la
maison pour payer ses dettes le ccdh
sidikou sont instaurées depuis des
années il n'accéda qu'il s'instaurer
nous avons obtenu l'adresse de celle qui
canalise melchisédech gabriel fréchette
qui habite victoriaville ok
excusez moi j'entendais pas besoin parce
que j'avais pas de crier c'est bien
celui-là
le changement est fille du scénic cedex
et si oui c'est l'annoncé mois
bonjour je m'excuse je voyais fiducie
jette ça doit être un but route c'est
pour ça que c'est pour enquête
nous apprenons que le groupe n'a pas
cessé ses activités depuis la mort de
chantal lavigne gabriel fréchette donne
toujours des formations elle nous
apprend aussi que la relève est assurée
dans le groupe melchisédech sinon si
c'est l'urgence en fait pas besoin
d'amener ma fille qu'elle anime
l'atelier
oui oui alors qu'elle réalise la bonne
affaire là
la fille de gabrielle fréchette et son
conjoint qui se font appeler main oui et
esteban sont maintenant les deux
formateurs les plus actifs du groupe
il n'était pas là lors de la sudation
mais ce sont eux qui loue la maison de
durham sud où est décédé chantal lavigne
maison où les groupes sont revenus et
dernièrement est ce que les activités
ont repris
oui je l'entends pas de cris par contre
côté je peux poser que c'est la même
chose qui se passe là sauf que je revois
encore les recoupements des groupes de
personnes marchent et le de différentes
âge puis de ses peaux des gens de la
place pour les gens que je connais
qu'est-ce que vous passez du fait que le
groupe continue ses activités
c'est quasiment un blasphème
je sais pas comment je veux dire tant
qu'à moi sts group le tac tout soit
réglé devrait même pas avoir le droit de
continuer les policiers les sorties du
québec ont ouvert une enquête
ils ont refusé notre demande d'entrevue
à ce jour aucune accusation n'a été
portée comme à sa fête celle que des
groupes qui ont autant de pouvoirs sur
les gens et qui parfois mettre les gens
à risque ne sont pas suivies davantage
au mois de novembre dernier aux états
unis james theuri un multimillionnaire
de la croissance personnelle a été jugé
coupable de négligence criminelle
cet homme qui avait fait les beaux jours
des talk shows américains organisaient
des huttes de sudation
en 2009 trois personnes sont mortes dans
l'une d'elles james theuri a été
condamné à deux ans de prison pour
chacun de ces décès à purger
simultanément il est actuellement en
prison
ce sont des groupes qui ne semble pas
catégorisé annule pas qu'ils sont
pauvres d'avoir de permis d'exercice
sont pas que je ne s'inscrire auprès du
ministère d'éducation ou donc une autre
instance rejointe au téléphone
gabriel fréchette nous dit n'avoir
aucune responsabilité quant à la mort de
chantal lavigne elle dit avoir fait son
devoir en appelant le 9 1 1
aucune des personnes présentes le 26
juillet dernier n'a voulu nous accorder
d'entrevue est-ce qu'elle ait pu y avoir
plus de morts salon définitivement les
conditions de cuisson comme ça ça aurait
pu être bien pire qu'un jour tu seras tu
as tu la santé elle est exposée jusqu'à
ce matin
mais elle est vraiment pas de quelque
chose il fallait qu'à suivre ses cours
le pour passer par dessus c'est quelque
chose qui était extrêmement important
son camp
[Musique]